the late Robin Williams will go down as
one of the most celebrated and deeply
loved actors of all time he got his
start in stand-up comedy and he never
gave up his tendency to ad-lib coming up
with jokes impressions and whatever else
popped into his agile mind here are some
of his funniest unscripted moments the
1997 film Good Will Hunting undoubtedly
hosts a fantastic script Matt Damon and
Ben Affleck wrote it to give themselves
great roles and they did just that with
their touching poignant story about a
Harvard janitor turned math genius they
won the Oscar for Best Original
Screenplay but an improvised moment by
their co-star may have just been the
film's most memorable scene Robin
Williams won an Oscar for his role as
dr. Shawn Maguire a psychology professor
and therapist to Will Hunting during one
session Shawn discusses the hilarious
and intimate memory of his late wife my
wife used to fart when she was nervous
she had all sorts a wonderful amazing
disease he was fused of heart and asleep
on the DVD commentary track a fleck and
a man revealed that Williams made up the
monologue on the spot and that Damon's
uproarious laughter was genuine in the
1987 film good morning Vietnam Williams
stars as a wild disc jockey on Armed
Forces radio in the middle of the
Vietnam War he angers his superiors by
playing rock and roll in R&B records and
by speaking out about the futility and
heartbreak of war the drama of wartime
is filtered through Williams presents
especially his motormouth scenes talking
about the escalating conflict the news
himself and the music we actually don't
have a teletype machine that's Fred
Astaire desi gaana hot plate Thank You
Fred
Williams's moments behind the mic feel
just like a real DJ's ramblings and to
maintain that authentic feel he was
given free rein in the film's production
notes producer Mark Johnson stated he
managed to create something new for
every single take the job related news
the Ku Klux Klan's uzi cartoon show
Casper the Friendly Ghost he's not fair
that he gets to float and we don't thank
you very much
when you absolutely have to be awake at
a certain time you've typically used a
loud and effective alarm clock but no
buzzer could wake someone up like the
booming familiar voice of Robin Williams
bursting into a comedy routine in 1988
NASA asked the comedian to make
wake-up call to the crew of the space
shuttle Discovery the first shuttle
flight after the 1986 challenger tragedy
so in a nod to his good morning Vietnam
catchphrase he shouted
good morning discovery rise and shine
boys time to stop doing that shuttle
shuffle you know what I mean NASA then
cut to a pre-recorded parody of the
Green Acres theme song with lyrics about
space but the song isn't that funny they
should have just let the clearly
thrilled Williams keep going 1996 is the
birdcage is an extremely silly farce the
plot concerns a young man who brings
home his fiancee and her extremely
straight-laced parents to meet his two
dads our monde and Albert played by
Williams and Nathan Lane Albert is a
drag performer so he dresses up as a
matronly old woman for the big dinner
with the inlaws everything goes wrong of
course particularly when Armand and
Albert's fake servant makes a soup but
no entree our Mons ducks into the
kitchen to freak out for a minute then
carry the soup pot back into the dining
room only to slip and fall
Williams sudden and spectacular tumble
was unexpected but he rolls with the
moment not once breaking character to
get a guest spot on The Tonight Show
during Johnny Carson's last week as host
was a very big deal set to retire after
nearly 30 years and as the undisputed
king of late-night
Carson was only going to invite his most
favorite and most entertaining guests
Robin Williams fit the bill so he
stopped by Carson's final regular
episode on May 21st 1992 Williams
roasted Carson with old man jokes
hitting the stage with a rocking chair
for the retiring comedian and yelling as
if he were hard of hearing
i'm afraid i also bought your the new la
MedicAlert it says I've fallen and get
the hell away from me before winning an
Oscar Williams won several Golden Globes
when he took on the prize for 1991's the
Fisher King his acceptance speech was as
pure perfect and definitive as a Robin
Williams routine could be he began with
a mildly suggestive joke about the look
of the trophy nothing on it how
appropriate
then he segwayed into current events in
the words of George Bush arigato
gozaimasu
and then he had some words for his
Fisher King co-stars before just going
off the rails in the most Robin Williams
way possible I'm just thanking everybody
now it's just like check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]